[Music]
i'm not the audio visual tech dude
no [ __ ]
yeah i'm not the dude who's like oh what
you need to do is get the dcp cube i
don't know what that means dcp
i wasn't going to say
like you're going to say pcp but just
like you're like ah that's too that's a
giveaway like you see this little
adapter
usb no i don't think so
well it's like a lightning bolt to a
headphone dongle
right took me so long to figure out
what it was
yeah it's a dongle
what did you say i'm pretty sure it's
called the dongle it's a dongle piece
some people call it yo is that got a
dongle
people call it a little dongle beast i
swear to god how do you spell dongle you
think d-o-n-g
i don't think anybody is sp dongle
d-u-n-d-o-n
dongle
that's how i always feel yeah
this is the dongle episode
i hope not i mean
[Laughter]
i'm gonna have to google the word dongle
okay as a matter of fact i'm gonna do it
right now
okay so dongle is that what we're saying
yeah yeah i think so
what is a dongle
i mean it may not like come up on
whatever but it's like if it isn't it's
like slang for whatever this piece is
dongle
that's exactly what came up
whoa a small
device able to be connected to and used
with a computer especially to allow
access to wireless broadband or use of
protected software so this maybe isn't a
dongle but it's pretty close actually
dongle you
this is exactly what i held up to you
yeah you can't see that because it's
white on white but yeah for trying
thanks for being racist
what
but you're the one who said white on
white not me
it was white it was the white piece on a
white background what the [ __ ] do you
mean listen dude just because you're
being racist you don't have to listen
man just because you're being
what what you gonna say
what are you gonna
it doesn't say if it's not ringing off
the wall
[Music]
[Music]